[Music]
your movie wanderlust which we're gonna
talk a lot about there's a lot of
references in the movie and I realize
it's true just looking at you now
characters actually other characters
talk about how beautiful your skin is
and then I see them in person and your
skin is just kind of perfect and I'm
wondering how you do that
don't touch it yeah I do you sort of
glow I don't know what it is your is it
your something you're eating an
interview I became obsessed with laser
porn and basically you know you is your
porn well I called it laser porn because
once somebody said you know I was like
yeah couple these sunspots cuz I like
the Sun you know I'm a California girl
and it's a hard habit to break
feel so good yeah but you know you get
to the place where it's like no then
maybe not so much and so I went and
investigated having some of those little
things apt and and I did this thing
called like a site appeal which is
extremely intense you don't really
understand that you actually look like
like like a battered burn victim for a
week and then and then it just falls off
starts to fall off your face fell off or
like a like eight days and then it just
Kip's yeah I was you it's gonna be
horrible we're fine I do have it
documented but it was horrifying you
hope you save the face afterwards so off
yeah you couldn't keep it in one intact
piece oh man that is eBay gold
No
[Laughter]